joe biden meeting with mexico's
president right now
while he undoes just about all of
trump's immigration policies
that's happening while biden's homeland
security secretary claims
everything is under control at the
border
do you believe that right now there is a
crisis at the border
i think that the uh the answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing
and we have our resources dedicated to
to managing it
really then why is the white house about
to open a new tent facility in texas to
handle a surge of migrants at the border
and what about border officials
reportedly saying they expect
13 000 unaccompanied children to cross
the border in may alone
but don't worry biden says it's all
under control
right now there's thousands of
unaccompanied children coming across the
border
in texas they opened up one one that was
a former
of one used in the in the administration
in the last administration
our hope and expectation is that won't
stay open very long
so juan jay johnson homeland security
director
under barack obama said that 1 000
illegal crossings a day constitute a
crisis
a three to four crossing three to four
thousand which we are a day right now
that must constitute a crisis wouldn't
you agree
yeah i mean now remember you've got a
number of people who've been waiting in
mexico and they're being allowed
entry and the question is you know what
do you do with those people can we
process them effectively jesse so i
think the numbers can get somewhat
confusing
but i i take what the homeland security
secretary said
right now he feels that it's manageable
obviously you can
you can come back and say to him in a
few weeks if that's not the case
uh that he wasn't telling the truth but
i think what we see today and you
mentioned this at the top is biden
meeting with the mexican
president uh obrador and you know
i think he's seeking help from mexico
from his other allies in latin america
because i think it's inevitable we're
going to see a spike
in real immigrants forcing in not just
crossing but forcing in in the
springtime of this year i think that's
one thing that we're going to see
so he needs help and it's not just from
some of these countries down in latin
america i think he needs help from
congress you know you think about it
obama increasing arrest increase in
deportations
we still saw spikes you think about
trump you know the fictional wall
uh the deportations the separating the
families
and we still saw spiders what do you say
fictional uh
the wall it's fictional uh but i i think
he needs help to set new tv
so we can deal with the immigrants who
are in this country
right now and i think we need to deal
with future flow we need to deal with
amnesty and we need to deal with border
security
i think 25 years is too long since
congress has acted so congress should
stop
playing politics and give give us
comprehensive immigration reform
okay well joe's border policy is
fictional in that case because it
doesn't exist
katie if he wanted mexico to help like
juan says then why do you get rid of the
remaining mexico policy
well first if the the wa the border wall
is fictional then i don't know why joe
biden ordered it for to stop
being built and why you have a number of
people who are working construction on
that wall
saying that they're no longer building
the wall that does exist
um but the dhs secretary today said
that he wanted people to come just not
right now so he said specifically it's
not that we don't want people to come
we just want to wait until we have time
to process all of them which is an open
invitation
for a mass increase in asylum fraud and
this is exactly what you're going to see
here
you had the prior administration make
sure put into place the remaining mexico
policy
and they worked with local governments
so people who actually apply for asylum
who are qualified
can apply in their home countries
because it's the first step
rather than making this long journey the
other thing that we're seeing here that
nobody is talking about
when you see the number that they're
predicting for 13 000 in may for example
how many times over is that going to
happen those kids are going to be here
the bite administration isn't going to
pay with taxpayer money to transfer them
to family members who are already in the
country living here most of them
illegally
and then in 20 years from now 15 years
from now we're going to have this
population of people
who came here through this process which
is going to set up another
immigration catastrophe and crisis
because you had now have a whole another
generation of quote dreamers
or other people who then they want to
make legal citizens and so
this is about asylum fraud and the
department of homeland security is
headed by a guy who today
invited this problem while claiming
there's no crisis going on
and it's one of their making in the past
few months one quick thing
biden also the ghs secretary today
lowered expectations saying that the
trump administration gutted everything
and that's why things are bad
they're just setting themselves up so
that when things get worse they can
blame it in the previous administration
dana your thoughts i'll just make a
quick one and that is that
juan mentioned the need for
comprehensive immigration reform and i
think there are many people in america
that would
welcome that but if if biden
loses control of this border issue like
if you know when majorca says
it's a challenge and we are managing it
like they better hope
that they can do that because if they
can't then any hopes of a
bipartisan immigration reform deal will
be out the window so
um if they really want to try to get
that done or anything else done
they've got to figure out a way to deal
with the immediate issue at hand
greg gutfeld so what uh first what
you're seeing is the great liberal flip
it's uh what was considered a crisis
when they are
out of power becomes a success when
they're
in charge so they actually insult their
own competence
by claiming this is their definition of
success
whereas republicans were like we got to
stop this and only a democrat would
condemn
a wall at a border but then appreciate
one surrounding the capital
i think that's a bit backwards also the
secret word obviously in all of this
is the word unaccompanied okay so can we
finally stop with the lie
about separating kids from their parents
when you're talking about 13 000
unaccompanied kids teens whatever you
call them
unaccompanied suddenly it's as if after
the election in november 13
000 pairs of parents just disappeared
and
and where did they go where did the
parents go
could it be that they really weren't
there to begin with and that we were
being fed
a heavily heavily lopsided story by the
media that favored the dems and didn't
favor trump
i would say so and what does it say
about mexico then if 13
000 of your young people want to get the
hell out
yeah that that's where the reform is
also not a bunch of
it's not a bunch of six-year-old girls
it's a bunch of 16 and 17 year old males
yeah those are the minors up next he was
just joking